welcome to philanthropy in action where
we engage philanthropist activists
students and the community in
discussions and how we use our time
talent and treasure to make the world a
better place
I am maxim thorn and I teach
philanthropy in action at Yale
today's guest is my good friend Daniel
Schwartz
thanks for coming Daniel thanks for
inviting me I'm honored
Daniel is the executive director of the
Elie Wiesel foundation we also have
yield University students as part of our
conversation and I welcome them to the
show please introduce yourself starting
with Jasmin my name is Jasmin I'm from
Hong Kong and I'm a senior economics
major my name is Marius and I'm a
sophomore and I'm a political science
major from Newmarket Delaware hi I'm
Connor I'm from Virginia and I'm a
junior majoring in history of science
and medicine hi I'm sunny I'm a student
from originally Switzerland Zurich and
I'm studying economics in my last year
hi my name is Ray Ibrahim I'm a freshman
from Flushing Michigan hi my name is
Brian I'm from Hong Kong I study
psychology and economics
Daniel it's so exciting to have you and
I think for all of our students engaged
in philanthropy you bring so many
different experiences as a
philanthropist yourself as a person
who's in who is advising many other
philanthropists as a person who advises
organizations engages in responding to a
number of international issues but you
didn't start that way you studied at
Harvard and you studied medieval what
was it medieval medieval philosophy
medieval philosophy how did you go from
that to becoming so engaged in the work
that you do I asked a lot of questions
and I've never stopped tell me about
these questions what kind of questions
were you asking
why do we exist why is there injustice
and then I started thinking well what
can we do to actually change the
equation and was there did you what what
propelled it though was there a
catalytic moment where youth where you
saw injustice that says I need to
respond yes a couple of things one being
a freshman studying in college the great
questions of life why do we exist is
there God is fabulous until something
happened and I was almost killed and
that had an amazing effect at focusing
my attention on why am I on this planet
when did that happen I was I was about
the same age as your students and I had
spent the semester in Jerusalem and was
on the west bank and a Molotov cocktail
came through a window on my bus was
flaming and hadn't cracked and I'm glad
that it was a defective maker and
soldier grabbed the bottle the flaming
bottle through it all and there's a
giant explosion shattering the glass on
the bus and I was covered in blood and
cut and that made me realize I'm so
lucky to be alive and shortly thereafter
I felt and had the outcome not been this
way what difference did I make in the
world now you're a good friend so a few
years ago I remember you telling me that
you were in a ph.d program at Harvard
but you left to take over the family
business tell us a little bit about that
and and with at which point then you
refocus your energy is elsewhere I found
it was very easy to be a student I was
the I felt like I was the luckiest
person in the world to have the
opportunity to read to study to ask
questions to meet the most interesting
people I could have mad
meeting and then my family at a small
business it was struggling and for the
first time in my life I heard fear in my
parents voice fear of not being able to
afford to live in our home to be able to
afford to pay for dinner to not to know
what to do next
and I thought I might be able to help I
was lucky to be able to help and have
the opportunity to leave sort of the
lofty world of the ivory tower to
something very very mundane and keeping
some people employed my family included
since I know part of the answer this
what is your big success with your
business and did that help you later on
into things that you have now done I
think to me big success is having
wonderful friends like you and I thank
you and a network and feeling like we're
making a difference in the world that's
success the businesses that I've had
have taken me to some of the poorest
parts of the world economically in some
of the richest parts of the world
culturally and socially it was getting
to make friends and meet people on the
ground that gave me the opportunity feel
more a part of something larger than
what I had anticipated as a child and
just briefly run me through from dynamic
ax to some of the things you have done
that brought you to the Elie Wiesel
foundation I think it's amazing up I had
two heroes my parents generation was
talking about different ones but my two
heroes as a child were and continued to
be Elie Wiesel and Nelson Mandela and I
saw two people who were giving voice to
people who needed to be heard fighting
injustice intolerance in a very brave
way and actually making a difference
that inspired me as a young person and I
thought I'll have no
Who am I not too much money no
connections no but it didn't stop me and
I always wanted to intervene where I
could and very little local things that
became a part of life and I've been
blessed to have the opportunity to do it
now larger and larger ways right
well that's let's go to Jasmine thank
you so much for coming so my question is
that for the Elie Wiesel foundation
basically there was the Madoff Ponzi
scheme which caused it to loss almost
all of its assets and so my question is
like how has this affected the
operations of the foundation and also
one comment that means mr. Wiesel made
was that banks can be bailed out like
automobile companies can be bailed out
there may be foundations sometimes
should be bailed out as well in certain
certain circumstances like this so I was
wondering what you make of that
statement and also what do you think is
the role of foundations in today's
society and economy thank you you've
done your research foundations needing
to be bailed out or the role of
foundations I find I always try to focus
on what's the purpose of the foundation
we're here to serve whom are we serving
whom are we attempting to serve those
people deserve to be helped and if
they're worthy of being helped whatever
mechanisms whether it's funding a
foundation volunteering your time let's
help people who are less fortunate than
ourselves the role of foundation I think
is a method of organization to be able
to provide that service what do you
think you asked the question you thought
about it so I think that foundations
itself like it has a you know it has an
important role in helping organizations
do the work that they want to accomplish
at the same time they also have a
financial
responsibility to its donors which I
find it's like an interesting tension so
say if it wasn't the Madoff Ponzi scheme
but it was the financial crisis that
cost you know the foundation to lose its
assets or it was some kind of
mismanagement of money how would you
feel that foundations are endowed with
public trust we have a phenomenal
obligation to the donors the recipients
the foundation itself I reengaged with
Professor Wiesel after I read about the
Foundation's loss in the Madoff scandal
and I basically knew the great work that
he was doing in the world and offered to
volunteer my time to be able to help him
I believe this is the area from the
smallest to the largest foundations
there's a difference between an
investment in financial markets that
might go up and down and the type of
concentration of financial assets that
many foundations did one of the reasons
why I'm so proud to be part of what
you're doing is a class studying
philanthropy studying best practice
would be hopefully to avoid those types
of investment decisions in the future of
scandal and and about investments what
what is the role of of investments for
financial investments for foundations
but more generally how does
sustainability of a foundation how does
that play into the Elie Wiesel
foundation I think specifically for
louise el foundation or variety of
others I almost feel like I'd like the
need for foundations and NGOs to be
wiped off the face of the earth if there
were equality fairness access to
resources health
there might be less need so in terms of
the role toward perpetuity perpetuation
I think foundations and good-hearted
people should exist and keep struggling
until the problems the wrongs were
trying to write go away and nothing
gives me more pleasure than to see a
foundation solve a problem close its
doors and move on to do other good work
or have the individuals move on to do
other good work what do you think right
I mean the reason why I was asking was
because a previous guest had told us
that she has a time limit to her
organization and that it is going to
last for 20 years and though close the
doors after that and pass on the work of
that organization which is to promote
school schools in in Guatemala and to
the local people and that kind of thing
and I guess I was I was just curious I
see a lot of foundations which are
focused on sustainability for for
perpetuity okay I was trying to I think
to think through that all right so I'm
actually really curious to hear what you
think but my feeling is it needs to be
focused a foundation should be focused
on what we're trying to achieve if it's
eradication of smallpox and we're able
to eliminate that disease and then close
the doors so be it if it's writing
social wrongs but to me there's a
difference between private foundations
individual donors groups of donors and
public charities I think that an
individual after paying taxes and
whatever is required you should be able
to spend the resources in a responsible
way but if it's your money you can
choose whether you'd like 20 years one
year or try to set something up in
perpetuity that's your right to me I'd
be less my suggestion or that what I
constantly question myself is I don't
care about the money the foundation /
are we solving the problem do we
have the right stakeholders at the table
what did you what was your reaction when
you heard that
20 years yeah I mean I I guess it was my
first instinct was was similar that I
guess the time limit wasn't what was
interesting to me but whether the the
goal would be achieved and I guess I was
curious also if maybe the goal isn't
achieved through the methods of the
foundation or the charitable work
maybe there's another method that should
be approached and I think you're right I
mean to me that one of the questions is
if the model of a foundation is a donor
or group of donors dispersing resources
a model if the model of a foundation is
doing good and achieving measurable
outcomes sometimes that's a different
model I'm much more of fan of trying to
measure what we're trying to achieve to
make sure we have an inclusive feedback
loop so that it's not a question of a
donor deciding what's best for this poor
person or this person in need I'd rather
people tell me what they need or tell us
what they need and then we can team team
up to try to solve it and provide what
Daniel do you have an opinion then on
this long-standing debate about the dead
hand whether a philanthropist should
engage in his or her philanthropy while
they're alive so that they have some
amount of input and control or whether
they should in fact set up something
that survives them after their death in
perpetuity or some limited time frame
Bill Gates of course actually has a
limited time frame to which the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation will continue
to exist so as to prevent sort of a
previous generations thoughts on
philanthropy affecting a future
generation I think it touches on in my
opinion touches on two things and I'd
love to learn from the class but
basically it's what's the most effective
way to address the challenge perpetuity
versus spend down immediately to me
seems arbitrary if you're not taking the
problems into account if there are
issues of injustice what will it take to
solve the problem it raises a broader
issue up is the foundation the exclusive
vehicle to do that
what's the broader coalition but to me
the questions of perpetuity spend-down
or not I find less compelling than what
are the most effective ways to address
challenging issues so my question is
relating to a debate that we frequently
have in our class which is the overlap
between political advocacy and
philanthropy and I wanted to bring up
something that is back from 2008 the
your foundation awarded french president
nicolas sarkozy with the Foundation's
humanitarian award and the reasons for
that were quote his commitment to renew
and strengthen Frances ties to United
States his steadfast support of Israel
and his global humanitarian efforts I
was wondering if you could elaborate on
how those first two points fit into the
definition of philanthropy and the
relationship between political support
and philanthropic issues I think that's
a wonderful question
and I will reiterate I joined the
foundation after that time right so I'm
trying to understand one of the things
that's important is awards and
recognition you were awarded with
admission to a fine university many of
you have told me about other awards and
honors and like my feeling is an award
has multiple purposes one of which is to
recognize great works that have been
achieved the second is to inspire people
to action if you look at the Wiesel
foundation response after giving this
award or specifically Elie Wiesel --zz
responses to some of the actions of
President Sarkozy
specifically visa vie the Roma community
I think that even though an award was
given to someone who's committed to
humanitarian results when he's acting in
a way that the foundation didn't find
consistent with its ethics and values
when he was acting in a way that made us
question pressure Raziel was comfortable
criticizing so there was actually some
debate about whether some of the actions
happened after the award so the award
was given and much more recently there
were some actions that didn't seem
necessarily consistent with the values
of the foundation and the board of the
foundation and even though president
Sarkozy has been a friend and an ally of
the foundation a variety of humanitarian
pro-democracy inclusive activities when
certain actions didn't seem consistent
professor Wiesel intervened what about
even not just after the giving the
president the award the initial action
of giving a head of state a humanitarian
award for you know philanthropic efforts
it's an ongoing debate and I'm glad that
you raised the question I actually want
to turn around and ask your opinion but
I had this question when I see heads of
state winning awards I have the question
when I see super affluent individuals
receiving humanitarian awards where
sometimes it's interesting to me is it
for the work they're doing they're about
to do or the financial contribution that
someone's hoping to receive and the
Nobel prizes specifically there are
people who have been awarded prizes
where it wasn't obvious to me why that
prize was awarded free post good deeds
so I think that Wiesel foundation award
Awards are tricky what's your opinion
well I think that any kind of
philanthropic initiative is going to be
infused with the political values and
kind of worldview
that body has I think it's an
interesting question of you know then
the message that it sends to potential
supporters of that initiative and
whether that's inclusive of you know a
wide sector the population you know and
would you know this award to the
president encourage a lot of people to
give to the foundation or not I think is
an interesting topic to discuss you
think it should or shouldn't I think it
will motivate some people to give and I
think it won't for others do you have a
distinction in your in your head between
political action versus non political
action as and are they both covered by
philanthropy in much of the world where
I have experience it takes both to try
to support and what might be considered
traditional philanthropy ignoring the
power and the politics can be very
frustrating just focusing on the
politics is also dangerous and to me
it's it's the balance and I see that in
the United States on a national state
regional level I see it throughout the
developing world I see it basically
wherever wherever I go it's very hard to
find large complicated issues that don't
touch on politics sunny may be playing
up a little bit on Connors question and
some of the things that have been
previously said I sense that there are
different approaches that well every
foundation your foundation as well takes
to harness change and particularly
positive change in resolve issues I
guess just to sort of get a summary or a
more inclusive view on it what is your
theory of change
oh one of the things in my experience so
far it's been most effective bridging
leadership being phenomenally inclusive
to all stakeholders and developing
relationships of mutual trust and
respect if you have the mutual trust and
respect you bridge leadership across the
multiple stakeholders I've seen amazing
things happen do you think it's more
bottom-up or do you think it's more
top-down or is it a balance of the two
what is what is stronger or is it if I
had to choose one I would speak to the
people we need change most and I would
err in the door we tend toward the
direction of listen to the people who
want something to change thank you all
right my question relates somewhat to
Sonny's question is how do you measure
the success of an investment investment
that you've made an organization how it
ranges from our education to healthcare
and if it doesn't have concrete or
immediate returns how do you know that
you've made an impact I think that's a
challenge with which I've been
struggling my entire life and I think I
will continue to struggle and I balance
between statistics regression analysis
quantitative metrics and the pooling at
heartstrings how can I say no when
someone pulls at my heart stream when
there's an immediate person and I'm
looking at her in the face and I know I
might be able to help her and in so
doing that might not be able to help all
of us that is beyond statistics
it's the one-on-one but without
measuring the things where there can be
a measurement
I think it's ignoring reality and it's
leads to tremendous inefficiency certain
I find certain things better tend toward
measurement certain things are more
experimental and emotional and it's
sometimes cyclical what's your opinion
the work that you've been doing for it's
been mostly or with the impact that
we've we can make as an individual I
find can't be measured exactly when it's
such a short time span if I would do
work in Ecuador that I've done over the
spring break you know that you can't
make a huge difference in the time that
you're there but the emotional aspect of
it I think overpowers good so my
question is the difference that you're
making there for the people who are on
the ground and is or is the difference
the difference it's making in you I
believe it's a combination of both their
response kind of fosters what difference
it makes in me and how I change as a
result of helping I think that's great
and what I found some of the
relationships I built when I was your
age those relationships continue I'm
still in touch with those people so even
what seems like a short time if they
feel comfortable calling me and I feel
comfortable being in touch with them and
now it's easier and easier to penetrate
so much more of the world those little
steps it's not the act in my mind is not
the finite action of that many days or
weeks it's building a network of trust
thank you for speaking to us today in
our class when we talk about foundations
there's always an element of cost
effectiveness so regarding your
foundation especially when your mission
statement is fighting and tolerance to
fighting injustice do you find it hard
to come up with metrics to to evaluate
the effectiveness of any of your program
how do you go about choosing which
program to pursue or expanding or or
developing in each in your program given
the five and limited financial resources
right so one of the things that the
Wiesel foundation has been doing for
decades is convening and bridging
networks and bridging leadership and in
terms of evaluating ethic
the impact it's bringing people together
who might not know each other bring
stakeholders for multiple sides of an
issue from the variety of disciplines so
when we're looking at measuring efficacy
what are the projects that arise from
fostering those relationships and
bringing people together or amplifying
good work so our annual conference of
Nobel laureates brings together
laureates but many other heads of state
and various stakeholders what we're
trying to do is create start the process
of building those networks and hope that
we're bringing the right people to the
table in areas that we're able to
measure that efficacy and others are as
well what do you think I mean I agree
with you and I think especially with a
mission such as such a broad like
mission statement not broad but like
fighting injustice is a really broad
topic I feel like there's always an
element of trust so bridging leadership
is really important so just exploring
these ideas one thing that we've been
trying to do for decades is look at
college students people your age what
are the ethical issues that are
important to you and what can we do to
amplify some of those questions and
issues I mean your University Press a
couple of months ago published a book of
the collected essays of college students
around the country who are dealing and
PACA trying to tackle ethical issues
it's one of the ways of the foundation
is trying to support the inquiry and I
hope it helps and now with internet
there's even more that we could be doing
Daniel do you weigh in on what you said
a little while ago things that are
experimental things that carry a lot of
risk that they actually will not
immediately if ever have a have a
benefit you know in business school
that's really easy because one of the
Assumption
that has made a business school as most
businesses fail and so the outliers are
the one that we hear about because
they've survived and philanthropy it's
so hard to tell donors well you know
most things fail and but still invest
how do you balance and how do you talk
to donors about the potential failure of
their investment to me I actually ask
more questions than tell donors I find I
learn more that way I think there's a
difference between doing something that
other people have done and there are
results and blindly going in and
ignoring history and precedent versus
experimenting in a new area that really
hasn't been as well researched so the
questions that I'll ask for donors who
are going into areas that look more
based on emotion than outcomes what's
the competitive landscape what's
happened there before why are you trying
this approach as opposed to the other
ones and I find that the portfolio
theory of tried and true well researched
experimentation in the blend in between
and you would support any of those
choices given the donors preference I
would support personally I find it's
easier to support those choices that
seem to be addressing the underlying
problem the challenge and if the people
who are actively involved in that space
are participants in the decision I find
it's much easier to support the
challenges are the Caprice of donors one
of the challenges and I find that it's I
believe that someone should be able to
spend their money as long as they're
doing no harm if they want to use it on
a plane or on ice cream be my guest if
they've earned it in an honest way but
if they're going to try to make the
world better I think we all have an
obligation to try to do that as
efficiently as possible and ask our
friends the questions that might help
the
the appropriate answer and make sure
there are the right people in the room
what do you think well I have a concern
when one is advising the super-wealthy
the folks with outlandish fortunes
because should an individual after
they've paid taxes and so forth that
you've set up be able to effectuate his
or her own foreign policy you're part of
a country and the country has a foreign
policy but given your kind of wealth I
don't mean yours but but I mean given
one's kinds of wealth you can in fact
become your own foreign policy change
maker that could be opposed to the
nation in which you're from does and to
me that tension is problematic and that
must happen with some of the issues
you've involved in I see it all the time
around the world to me the solution or
part of the solution will be broad-based
inclusive representative democracy of
well educated populace if you have that
it's much harder for an individual donor
no matter what the resources are to
effect a change that's not for the
public good
thank you now Daniel I ask this question
if you knew then what you know now as
our parting words to our students what
would you do differently
I think the things that I would do
differently are to be much more
appreciative of every minute of the day
and how I spend time and the things and
to have the courage and the
self-confidence to work on some of the
individual emotional challenges that
I've had in my own development to have
the pride to exhibit and exert the moral
courage to do the right thing to
intervene when I might have otherwise
been tempted to stand silent well thank
you Daniel Daniel Schwartz the executive
director of the Elie Wiesel foundation
himself a successful businessman himself
a successful philanthropist and advisor
to major donors around the world thank
you for being here Daniel thank you for
inviting me and thank you to our yell
students for their very very thoughtful
questions that enriched the conversation
today this has been philanthropy in
action as Daniel passionately stated we
all have a part to play in making the
world a better place he challenged us to
change the way that we deal with each
other to appreciate every moment in the
day and I hope that we take that to
heart now what are you going to do to
change the world